Let's go to our caller from the three zero
five area code color from three zero five.
What's on your mind today?
Hey, David. Um, this is Esteban, uh, currently,
uh, in Atlanta, Georgia, but I reside in Orlando.
All right. Um, so as you know, uh, Pelosi
has been withholding the articles of impeachment
for a couple of weeks now. I think this is
really genius. I need to meet, you know, she
might say that she's doing this because she
wants, you know, uh, to guarantee your free
trial. But I think it's really clear that
she's just trying to make us a word, a word
of attrition. Um, you know, more and more
devastating information comes out with Trump.
More and more scandals become public and you
know, he's still serving as an impeached president.
So, you know, Shirley just can't look, uh,
right. You know, uh, emails just came out
highlighting the fact that Trump was the one
who made the order to withhold the aid. And
you know, Trump is, might argue, uh, that,
you know, the Democrats are scared.
But I think that, you know, it's really clear
that she's doing this maybe to, I guess sort
of muddy Trump's name. Um, you know, a five
through eight poll just came out and support
for a removal of office for Trump has reached
57%, which is the highest it's ever been.
So my question is, you know, what's your take
on this? Uh, but more specifically, how long
do you think the Democrats should continue
the strategy? And you think that all this,
uh, bad information coming out on shrunk,
um, is going to weaken, uh, chances of winning.
Okay, good. So a lot of good questions there.
I do think that in the immediate, the withholding
of the articles of impeachment from the Senate
is a smart move. I said it before, a Donald
Trump has an impeached president is becoming
increasingly erratic. You know, the problem
is that he may become so erratic that he does
things that lead to the deaths of tons of
people like starting a war with Iran because
he thinks it'll help him get reelected. So
that is definitely a concern. But so far the
articles of impeachment being withheld is
a throat know, making Trump even more erratic.
You're absolutely correct that we are learning
more and more things. In fact, those emails
showing that Donald Trump was the one ordering
the Ukrainian aid be withheld. Those are emails
that were denied to the house during the impeachment,
uh, inquiry and investigation, which Mitch
McConnell also wanted to exclude from the
Senate trial.
And how do you justify excluding those from
the Senate trial at this point, given that
they have gone public? So I agree with all
of that stuff. The concern I have is if you
hold impeachment until after the November
of 2020 election, if you withhold the articles
from the Senate until after the 2020 election,
I think that Trump may be, gets himself reelected,
uh, because it doesn't do any, the, the trial
doesn't do any damage to Trump. At the same
time, there's a risk that if you start the
impeachment trial in July, in August, the
Republican national convention is in August,
that Trump and Republicans are successfully
able to paint Democrats as merely political
and calculating. And it could actually inspire
people to get out there and vote for Trump
because he convinces them that he's the victim
and he's a martyr. So I think in general,
this has been a good decision by Nancy Pelosi.
I'm not sure of the end game, and I'm not
sure at what point it might backfire.
Right. Uh, I remember, uh, watching, I don't
remember what news kind was on, but, uh, there's
this guy named Island venturing. Apparently
he's like a, he's correctly predicted like
every election since 1980.
Oh, Alan Lichtman. Yeah, we've interviewed
him on the show.
Yeah. Oh, really? Interesting. So he said
that there's, um, there's like 13 factors
that, uh, sort of make up or decide, uh, the
chances of a president being elected or reelected.
And, um, I think some, like they consisted
of like, you know, scandals, but one of the
big ones was like in teaching, um, he said
that, uh, at least he's, he claims that the
only way Trump would lose the election is,
uh, if you know, the Democrats move forward
with impeachment and it doesn't matter, you
know, if he's actually successfully removed
from office, all that matters is, um, that,
you know, there's, there's obviously going
to be a trial. Um, and I think that the more,
you know, the more Nancy withholds of these
articles, I think the harder it is to deny
Trump, you know, an impeachment trial. I in
the Senate. Um, which I think ultimately would
just, you know, um, increase his chances of
losing the real life.
You may be right. I'm not sure. And I know
Alan Lichtman is well respected and I, I T
to me it's, it's less clear, but uh, we're,
we're, we've only got 10 months left, so we're
going to know pretty soon.
Yeah.
All right. Thank you so much for the call.
I appreciate it. Thank you so much. That is
all the time I have today. Apologies to everybody.
I was not [inaudible]
able to get to, but we have, we have all year
to take phone calls, so we'll take a quick
break and be back with more afterwards.